hi
tim baker i'm ready for your adventure i
will go to
i
hey all this is graham crutch with new
media rockstars
i'm coming to you from the video game
high school season 3 premiere
i'm working on leveling up my youtuber
interviewing skills
let's go
what is your high score 120
000 what is your power up of choice one
billion dollars and what is your secret
weapon my secret weapon
a disarming smile he's so charming
what's your high score what's your
favorite power-up
do you like candy how many enemies do
you have
all of them how many have you destroyed
all of them brilliant now
slo-mo oh yeah
oh how proud are you three seasons in
super proud tonight is a culmination of
the very weird dream
four years ago when five nerds sat on a
couch and said
hey how about video game high school is
that an idea
will do the actors break a lot during
filming i wasn't on set you gotta
understand that like when
it comes time to shoot the show i hide
jimmy jimmy what was your favorite
moment on set
uh
ah i'm in the parking lot i forgot to
save my game
i'm here with the big bosses this is the
hardest interview you will ever do if
you say ah or um once it's over
how do you feel now that it's done good
what was your favorite episode in the
first season to shoot it's my show so of
course i like all the episodes equally
nice what are you going to do next not
answer this question
what do you think the true legacy of
video game high school will be
thank you gentlemen
awkward
well ladies and gentlemen and everyone
in between i've leveled up to the point
where i mean
moderately decent nay excellent
interviewer of youtubers
please like and comment this video tell
us what your power ups are
and please subscribe to new media
rockstars thanks